there is one more spot in our lineup
that the team has been working really
hard to fill
yes and I am so excited and thrilled to
show it to you now and no they are not
going to show it to you because the
launch of the Apple silicon Mac Pro has
been delayed again and it seems like
this machine is turning into a fail here
and I'm saying that from somebody who
has loved the Mac Pro both the 2019
model along with the trash can Mac Pro
which was actually the first ever Mac
that I bought and used now we have been
talking about the launch of the Apple
silicon Mac Pro for a while now because
it is the last Intel based Mac that has
not been upgraded and unfortunately as
time goes on is has been delayed and
gotten worse and worse when Apple
announced their amazing new processors
at WWDC in 2020 they said that we're
gonna have a two-year transition of
course we got the new M2 MacBook Air and
13-inch MacBook Pro but no Mac Pro came
out so then everybody figured alright
fall time if we count the transition
from when the M1 MacBook Air and Mac
Mini launched that would be perfect and
then it also didn't launch again and now
Mark German just came out and he
reported that the Apple silk and Mac Pro
will no longer be coming at WWDC and
they are not even going to be talking
about it so in this video I'm gonna
update you with everything we know about
this machine and what this delay could
lead to as far as the chipset that is
being used the performance and the setup
now the crazy thing is we had so many
leaks about the M1 extreme chin and not
only leaks but the same guy that
revealed Mac Studio before anybody even
knew about it gave us info almost a year
ago about a 40 core CPU based extreme
chip being tested with his friend
actually using it and testing out the
slots and then Mark German gave us the
news that this extreme chip has been
canceled and with that he said that the
Mac Pro was completely ready but Apple
was delaying it and as you guys know we
do some very in-depth testing and the
only reason that would make sense to
cancel this chip that was made is
because it didn't perform up to par and
we found with the M1 Ultra that the
scaling was terrible Even in our
toughest torture test spending three
times as much money as the base the
performance barely got better and thanks
to some awesome Engineers we figured out
why and that is Apple's 32 megabyte tlb
bottleneck that made Graphics scaling in
particular very bad and because of that
with an extreme chip it would be even
worse so that left us with just an M2
Ultra in a Mac Pro which doesn't seem
very great because the Amon Ultras in
the Max studio are ready and Mac Pros
can get up to a crazy about fifty
thousand dollar price and apple will be
limited in what they could charge now
along with that we got more bad news the
first one is that the Mac Pro would lack
expandable Ram all together and that was
really weird because last year Majin Buu
showed off this memory controller that
is designed for the Mac Pro to allow for
external Mac memory it's called Daisy XL
and it can allow for up to one terabyte
to be used in conjunction with a unified
memory that is built onto a chip and the
only reason to cancel that would be if
performance just was not good enough and
then after that Margaret came out and
said that the Mac Pro May lack user
upgradable Graphics which has been a
staple with the professional Macs being
able to put in more Graphics units be
able to get better performance that was
such a blow and now the reason the
original trash can failed and apple
admitting it themselves was the fact
that you could not upgrade and for years
it just sat there and they gave us the
iMac Pro just because of that so many
people were upset and they couldn't do
anything about it and they promised us
that this new Mac Pro is going to be
modular they are not going to fall
behind in upgrades and guess what it
launched in 2019 here we are in 2023 and
it is outdated nothing has changed they
gave us a couple graphics cards a year
after AMD announced them and it's
another device that is just sitting
there and not doing a good job and now
with this news that it is not going to
be released again well that just pushes
that back even further so why would
Apple want to do this and why is it
becoming such a failure well the first
reason is because Apple may be
completely rethinking this machine
because they are having issues with the
higher end chip the memory things like
that we saw that initially it was
supposed to be a smaller design but then
that was scrapped for a larger one and
that already says something and then
recently we had a leak that we have a
new code that is referencing compute
modules which could be used in the Mac
Pro and the interesting is these compute
modules are listed as 13-1 and 13-3
which is a typical naming scheme that
Apple uses for their Macs now we've
talked about this in the past but the
idea is just like Jeff Benjamin pointed
out that we can have a module that has
the CPU the GPU and the memory on it and
you can actually swap them out and keep
the rest of the computer now a lot of
the cost comes from that massive case
which now they are keeping you have the
power supply you have your storage you
have your fans all the Thunderbolt ports
that are there and so all that will stay
you pop a new card in and then you can
easily upgrade it and then it'll make it
a lot easier for Apple instead of
getting stuck not upgrading for a long
time to be able to offer these once
every site will say a year and a half
now if that was a change that they made
that makes sense why the Mac Pro is
getting delayed again now apart from
that there are two other scenarios why
it is delayed the first one could just
be that right now we're in a really
recessionary time they have other things
they want to put out like the 15-inch
MacBook Air that will sell much better
and because other things got delayed
they want to push this back and whatever
plans were in place with the M2 Ultra
they are going to keep that but the
third option is that they maybe are
waiting for the M3 series of chips to
put in here now those chips are going to
be much better than the M2 which we've
called a stop Gap numerous times we know
that the M3 chips are going to be coming
out in the fall and Mark Airman says
that the Mac Pro could now be announced
in the fall tsmc the fabricator of these
chips just put out in their earnings
that in the fall quarter three they're
gonna make a lot of money from their N3
process which is three nanometer for the
chips so the previous issue I mentioned
where the scaling was not good with this
whole new architecture that is going to
be much better and if they decide to
give us a big powerful chip and a
powerful standard computer well that's
going to work a lot better with that
chipset and personally what I've
believed is that the people that are
buying the base ship they don't care
about performance as much if they're
buying a MacBook Air even the M1 is good
enough so if they want to create a
computer which is super powerful that is
where you need three nanometer to have a
better scaling and performance and the
pros actually care about it and then the
volume is lower as well so it's easier
to make so while it does suck to have to
wait even longer for the machine and
apple had to break their promised
two-year transition point I think if
that's going to be the case it's going
to be a lot better of a result than them
cutting back the powerful processors
getting rid of a lot of features that we
cared about and giving us pretty much a
Mac Studio but in a bigger case you guys
let me know your thoughts click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those videos right over there and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]